did you guys hear that
imagine it you're home alone something
goes bump in the night
what was it a cat a burglar or maybe a
ghost
our minds are big and they require
furnishing
for humans any answer is preferable to
the terror of not knowing
so we automatically create causes to go
with our effects
conventional or otherwise unfortunately
the real world is complicated and cause
and effect
are murky even in carefully controlled
studies what works in one place might
not work somewhere else
and if an experiment can't be replicated
should it be trusted in the first place
as historian daniel borstman said the
greatest obstacle to progress
is not ignorance but the illusion of
knowledge harvard professor vikram
mantra amani recommends diversifying our
sources
and developing our own judgment rather
than relying just on experts
our decisions are always based on
personal knowledge and that can be scary
but in a world defined by contingency
and uncertainty
we just have to take a chance
when it comes to public policy what are
you most afraid of
let us know in our poll also let us know
what other topics you'd like our
scholars to cover in 60 seconds
and be sure to like and subscribe for
more research and videos
from aei